[Musique]
mais bon soit richard berner merci
d'être avec nous on va rétablir la
liaison on aurait dû vous avoir un petit
peu plus tôt j'explique ça pour nos
téléspectateurs
le dirigeant donc un controversé qui a
démissionné officiellement ce soir
est-ce que selon vous cet été la bonne
décision
je me sens où il a été élu selon les
règles c'était des élections
démocratiques
les fautes en matière du point de vue
légal
il n'y avait aucun problème c'est
l'establishment politique et qui
paniquent et qui une fois de plus
mettez en avant les politiques de partis
la loyauté envers les partis et les
considérations des partis au dessus des
règles de la démocratie
et je ne pense pas que ça va être
appréciée par les électeurs je ne pense
pas que les électeurs seront très
contents
il sera intéressant de voir ce qui va
suivre
c'est vrai qu'il y avait une grosse
pression de l'impasse notamment de la
classe politique à commencer par la
chancelière allemande en tête un gala
merkel qui a qualifié d' acte
impardonnable cette alliance électorale
inédite
il a donc cédé à la pression il n'aurait
pas dû selon vous quelles étaient ses
politiques représentant le pape et le
temps des élections formelle utilisent
des voies que des hommes politiques
puissent utiliser leur devoir parfum
d'élire quelqu'un cela ne devrait pas
être controversé
et ce dirigeant qui ne l'a été que pour
24 heures puisque effectivement comme
l'avait dit il a démissionné et un
membre du parti fdp le parti libéral
démocrate qui est un parti traditionnel
donc rien ne justifiait vraiment cette
démission cela n'est pas vraiment contre
la démocratie
mais c'était un gros problème pour les
grands partis pour la céder ou de angela
merkel en particulier mais également
pour le parti libéral démocrate
au niveau national il ne souhaitait pas
ce résultat électoral car des membres
d'un autre parti ont donné des votes et
apparemment ils ne sont pas d'accord
avec les principes de ce parti mais
c'est très étrange lorsqu'on étudie la
situation car la personne et bus étaient
membres d'un parti traditionnel
mainstream et les personnes qui ont voté
pour lui certes était dans certains cas
d'autres partis mais ils ont voté pour
cette personne et si ces timbres si
c'était un bon homme politique alors il
aurait accepté le vote ce qu'il a fait
mais effectivement après lieu de la
pression au niveau national pour qu'il
démissionne donc c'est très étrange et
je pense que cela montre qu il y a un
problème sérieux en allemagne en matière
de politique des partis c'est un
problème fondamental
en général il s'agit d'illusions c'est
un manque de souveraineté car
l'allemagne n'est pas pleinement
souveraine elle n'est encore sous
occupation étrangère
une bonne partie des statuts
d'occupation sur le corps en place et
donc beaucoup de choses qui arrivent sur
la scène politique quelles sont les
conséquences de cela c'est vraiment
simplement du théâtre et je pense que
l'électorat s'en lasse de plus en plus
et que
c'est ce fiasco ne va pas aider les
partis traditionnels leur popularité
décline elle a réussi à berner vous
savez évidemment que ça a créé une onde
de choc en allemagne tout simplement
mettons les pieds dans le plat parce que
voilà c'est écrit partout dans la presse
allemande
ça a évidemment cet épisode a ravivé le
souvenir des années 30 lorsque le parti
d'adolphe hitler a fait alliance
justement avec la droite traditionnelle
parce que c'est ça qui est reprochée
clairement aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ces critiques et les
médias très très exagérées de rappeler
ma décision de faire des comparaisons
avec la période entre 1933 545 mais
c'est très populaire en allemagne fait
tout ans très souvent de comparaison
avec la période nazie et on mentionne
très souvent hitler le problème c'est
que c'est devenu un tel cliché peut quoi
qu'il arrive on y fait immédiatement
référence et les personnes et qui font
cela éculés cette comparaison plus
personne n'est choqué et ce n'est pas
une bonne chose parce que ces douze
années est effectivement tragique et
devrait scandalisé et choqué dans ce
qu'elles sont évoqués mais on le fait
trop souvent donc cette comparaison mais
pas vraiment pertinente en l'occurrence
tous les partis impliqués dans cette
affaire sont des partis majeurs et même
l'opposition la r d est maintenant un
parti très large une déclaration
concernant cette élection ne pourrait
choquer donc il ne s'agit pas de
personnes radicale avec des politiques
radicales il ne s'agit pas d'un
résidents des régions qui s'apprête à
mettre en place des politiques radicales
ça n'était pas le cas peut-être que j'ai
raté quelque chose c'est vraiment une
question de loyauté envers son parti est
une question des partis traditionnels ne
souhaitant pas être considéré comme
proche de ces partis plus récents qui
croise en ce moment même nous devrions
parler des grands problèmes politiques
ne devrions pas parler autant des partis
mais c'est triste à dire cela ne sommes
pas être dans l'intérêt des partis
traditionnels ne souhaite pas parler de
politique concrète et le débat ce
devrait être quel était le programme de
thomasg emery il n'avait aucune
politique qu'on polémique mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une rupture vraiment de ce
qu'on appelle le cordon sanitaire qui a
choqué beaucoup effectivement qu'en
pensent les allemands on a beaucoup
parlé des politiques mais les allemands
eux
quelle est leur opinion sur ce point
avec ce sommet la route et ouais ouais
je pense que c'est ce muller la
situation oreilles je suis il y a eu des
élections dont les résultats ne peut pas
apprécier par à l'establishment
notamment en angleterre on devra quitter
l'union européenne les partis
traditionnels ne s'y attendait pas on
était vraiment pris au dépourvu et c'est
ce qui arrive en allemagne
la majorité de la population n'ont même
pas des vues que comprennent aujourd'hui
les partis traditionnels qui semble être
vraiment dépassés par ce que pensent des
gens et ce qu'ils ressentent
c'est un problème fondamental et cet
événement à turin je montre bien l'écart
entre les personnes ordinaires ce
qu'elle pense
est ce que les partis traditionnels
souhaiterait comme nous voyons remus
mais la population gagnera sans doute
merci beaucoup richard werner d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous